ANKUR KOTWAL: Have
you ever wanted
to share a location
in your apps,
only to find that you're
dealing with mysterious numbers?
Users think of
their location based
on the place they're at, not
latitudes and longitudes.
The Places API for
Android solves this
by enabling you to
present locations
as meaningful entities.
Google's comprehensive and
trusted places database
contains businesses, pet stores,
shopping malls, embassies,
and of course, my
favorite, theme parks.
Google has more than 100 million
places from all over the world.
It's the most comprehensive
list of places you'll find.
I'm Ankur Kotwal, and
I'm going to show you
how to make location in
your app more personable.
This can take the
previous experience
and make it into
something like this.
The Places API
has been available
as a Google web
service for some time,
but it is now available
as a native Android API
through Google
Play Services 7.0,
meaning you can use it in
your Android apps right away,
supporting users all the
way back to Android 2.3
Gingerbread.
Being a native Android API
results in a more accurate list
of returned places, since the
user's current location can
be more reliably determined.
Now, perhaps the most
common question users
want to answer is, where am I?
The Places API makes it easy
for you to give them that answer
through the PlacePicker.
This is a ready-to-use
widget that displays
a list of nearby places.
And using it is as simple as
calling the PlacePicker to be
displayed.
The result is a
Place object, which
comes with really useful
details such as addresses,
phone numbers, and URLs.
Each Place has a unique place
ID, and you can cache this ID,
so that if you ever need to
retrieve that same place again,
you can do so easily using
the getPlaceByID() method.
If you don't want to
use the PlacePicker,
nearby places can be
programmatically retrieved
through the
getCurrentPlace() method.
Now, this API returns
a list of places
so that you can present them
in your own custom picker,
if you choose.
If you're like me, you don't
enjoy typing long place names
on mobile keyboards.
Chances are that your
users feel the same way.
The Autocomplete API delivers
suggested place names
and addresses, based on
what's been typed so far.
If however the user is not able
to find their place in the list
of results, you can ask
your users to add new places
and feed this data to Google
through the addPlace() method.
Now when adding a new
place, you can then
report that the user is at
that place via a PlaceReport.
And this captures signals
to identify that place
automatically in the future.
Newly added places will be
available to users in your app
and could ultimately be added
to Google's global places
database.
So when it comes to
location, the Places API
makes it really easy
to free your users
from a world of long,
mysterious numbers
by bringing real
entities to your apps.
The sample code at this
link contains everything
you need to get started
in dramatically improving
your users' location
experiences.
I look forward to seeing
what you build, using Places.